and so tonight
the new york mets
paid tribute
to the winningest left-handed pitcher
in franchise history
as we retire the number 36
worn for 12 years
with pride
and distinction
by jerry kuzman
well marcus going for his 10th win of
the season he has been solid on the
mound
and escobar drops down a bunch strowman
will goes to third for the tag a perfect
throw and he got him
you cannot make a more perfect throw
than the one marcus strowman just made
and he had to
against the speed of thomas put it right
on the bag for the tag by vr when the
bases are loaded big spot for yadiel
hernandez
and hernandez takes the backdoor slider
for strike recall well you got to go to
school on the home plate on fire las
diaz has been calling the pitch off the
plate this entire inning
little looper behind short into center
field here comes nimble to make the
catch and that retires the side
sean nolan three innings eight hits four
runs first time he faced the mets
on the breaking ball kibum
nicely done
a lot of baseball showing out of that
webbing he got rid of it josh made a
very good fit and nolan not far from
home a one two three first
and with uh some speed at second base
that's a nice move of the runner
he's going to drive one the other way
and it tails away from nimmo around to
score garcia lane thomas back in the
lead-off spot tonight pair of doubles
four total bases and he puts the nets on
top double double animal style
he's two for two with two doubles in the
second inning he's on pace to hit nine
doubles tonight
2-2
escobar the other way in the next lead
two-nothing 10-game hitting streak line
drive opposite field hitting at the top
of the order just a tremendous bad ball
hitter last night i said he was vladimir
guerrero senior light
it doesn't matter look where this pitch
is
he knew he knows there's a big strike
zone he knows that las diaz is ready to
ring him up and what does he do this is
what i'm talking about protect him with
two strikes putting the ball in play two
nothing so a two-nothing lead for sean
nolan the left-hander he'll face pete
alonso leading off the bottom of the
second inning
another one see ya
whoa
looks like the spiked curveball i see
the grip with the knuckle on it so a
knuckle curve
oh change up away unreachable they are
not happy in flushing
front door on the hook and josh bell
unhappy hitter unhappy fans
unhappy owner
nats are feeling pretty good in new york
right now though
kevin pillar leads off in the home third
against sean nolan who's based six and
retired six so far
gets a hold of this one deep left center
field back in the gap back near the wall
it's out of here
kevin pillar home run number 11. there's
a big hit
metzer on the board it's 2-1
oh you don't want to go to change up
belt high out over the plate
pilar just
let it weighted nicely
that's over the right wall of flushing
you see that grab
that's down two to one as they come to
bat against sean nolan in the bottom of
the fifth
pilar homart his first time up tonight
for the only mets run
another one deep to left by pilar
hernandez goes back and this falls out
of here
pilar ties the game with his second home
run of the night two long balls for
kevin pillar put in the lineup tonight
against the lefty
and pillar unloads his sixth career
multiple home run game is 12th home run
of the year and we're even 2-2
escobar long throw
oh my what a play
tremendous range a no look throw to
first right on target they just don't
give out gold gloves to anyone what a
play by ocd's escobar one out of one on
here's luis garcia who's walked and
struck out
and garcia had to double play ball right
tobias lendore with the easy part four
six three double play and just like that
a five pitch inning for marcus strowman
in the top of the sixth well warming up
for the nets there 26 year old patrick
murphy
and the fastball up chopped into the
ground
escobar a couple of crow hops and that's
it
the nationals bullpen in this series has
been nearly flawless
and the nats have runners at the corners
with two out third hit of the night for
el cider's escobar
he threw it away
here comes adams
nets are on top
try to make the perfect pitch to juan
soto throws the 59-foot off-speed pitch
i believe all the way to the screen
riley adams on his toes as he was the
whole time around the bases there the
infield single scrappy riley adams on
the bases flying all over the place
three to two nets
escobar at second with two out
and soto chases the slider for strike
three
rookie right-hander mason thompson on
the pitch conforto to
hits a rocket out to left center field
that goes thomas to the warning track at
the wall it's out of here
michael conforto with a pinch hit
three-run homer
and the mets are in front first career
pitch hit hold on from michael conforto
on the very first pitch drawn by mason
thompson and the mets have their first
lead
in this series that might have been the
most animated that i have ever seen
michael conforto
after hitting a home run jeff lugo he
didn't get it out the last time he
pitched day before yesterday
that's grounded down to first alonso's
got it out at second and gore back to
first in time three six three double
play
[Applause]
key boom goes down swinging on the high
fastball
and lugo takes care of the gnats in the
top of the eighth edwin diaz looking for
the save 5'3 new york as we go to the
ninth
and he unloads this one to center field
but in his tracks nemo
barely has to move an inch
one pitch one out
hit him to hit him or the bat hit him
he's trying to sell it and las diaz
sends him to first
1-2
little tapper
the zika will go to first with it two
out
one-two coming
he got him looking and the ball game is
over enough for the mets to snap a
four-game losing streak as they overcome
the nationals five to three to even up
this series
you